إذا كانت هناك أي فرصة لأن نكون قادرين على
التصرف بشكل بناء للقيام بشيء
ما، فسوف يتطلب ذلك الاعتراف
بالتعقيد والحفاظ على ما قد يبدو على
السطح
أفكارًا متناقضة مفادها أن ما فعلته حماس كان
مروعًا وليس هناك أي مبرر
له، وما هو صحيح أيضًا هو  أن
الاحتلال وما يحدث للفلسطينيين
أمر
لا يطاق، والصحيح أيضًا أن
هناك
تاريخًا للشعب اليهودي
قد يتم فصله ما لم يخبرك
أجدادك أو أجداد أجدادك أو عمك
أو خالتك
بقصص عن
جنون
معاداة السامية والصحيح هو أن
هناك أشخاصًا
يموتون الآن ولا علاقة لهم بما
فعلته حماس وما هو صحيح صحيح
يعني يمكننا أن نستمر لفترة من الوقت
والمشكلة مع وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي و  محاولة وضع علامة على
النشاط ومحاولة مناقشة هذا الأمر
هو أنك لا تستطيع قول الحقيقة،
يمكنك التظاهر بقول الحقيقة، يمكنك
التحدث بجانب واحد من
الحقيقة، وفي بعض الحالات، يمكنك محاولة
الحفاظ على براءتك الأخلاقية ولكن ذلك
فاز  لا تحل المشكلة، لذا إذا كنت
تريد حل المشكلة، فعليك
أن تأخذ
الحقيقة كاملة، ثم عليك أن
تعترف بأن لا أحد يداه
نظيفتان وأننا
جميعًا متواطئون إلى
حد ما.
ما الذي كان يمكنني فعله خلال فترة
رئاستي للمضي قدمًا بهذا الأمر بكل ما
حاولت، لدي الندوب لإثبات
ذلك ولكن هناك جزء مني لا يزال
يقول حسنًا، هل كان هناك شيء آخر كان
بإمكاني فعله وهو المحادثة التي أجريناها
يجب ألا ننظر إلى
الوراء فحسب، بل يجب أن نتطلع إلى الأمام،
وهذا لا يمكن أن يحدث
إذا اقتصرنا على
غضبنا، أفضل أن أراك هناك
تتحدث إلى
الأشخاص بما في ذلك الأشخاص الذين لا توافق
معهم إذا
كنت تريد حقًا تغيير
هذا، فأنت  عليك أن تعرف كيفية
التحدث إلى شخص ما على الجانب الآخر
والاستماع إليه وفهم ما
يتحدثون
عنه
وعدم
تجاهله لأنه لا يمكنك إنقاذ هذا الطفل
دون مساعدته في هذا الموقف